do you want to send her any well wishes
sure i don't want anyone to be heard
ellen degeneres is sending kind words to
her ex and heish amid her
hospitalization following her
life-threatening car crash
vehicle into a structure we also have a
structured fire two-story single-family
dwelling
heavy smoke showing keep everybody
coming while out and about in santa
barbara the former daytime talk show
host gave a brief comment on the actress
whom she dated from 1997 to 2000. have
you spoken to ann hesh at all since her
accident
do you want to
touch with each other so i wouldn't know
it's seemingly true ellen and anne have
had little to no communication since
they're split
that's something ann mentioned to et a
couple years ago alan and i haven't
spoken in years and uh
you know
in a relationship and i think many of us
have them
you come to a fork in the road what do
you want and what do i want
and
and
those goals that that intent in life
is uh determined by the individual
and
um her intent and my intent were
different and that's why we separated
but despite the two not being in touch
ellen still hopes and comes out of the
accident okay i don't want anyone to be
heard yeah it's quite a dangerous
accident that happened wasn't it
ellen and ann have a lot of history
together
back in the 90s their debut as a couple
wasn't welcomed with open arms i think
people have let go of this a little bit
i think they've calmed down and realized
that you know it's just
hopefully something that's like anybody
any other couple it's a moment in time
anne opened up about while she competed
on dancing with the stars in 2020. my
movie premiere volcano i had told them
that i was taking ellen as my date and i
was told if i took helen i would lose my
fox contract
at that moment she took my hand and said
do what they say
and i say no thanks
i took ellen to the premier i was
ushered out by security before the movie
even ended and told i was not allowed to
go to my own after party for fear that
they would get pictures of me with a
woman but despite those struggles years
later she sees the good that came from
that entire experience we went through
an incredible time and we were part of a
truly a part of a revolution that helped
move the needle and i i'm and i couldn't
be more grateful for that ellen and i
had a little bit different twist on the
story of what we were fighting for 20
years ago and fighting for equality and
i'm so thrilled to have been by her side
what i was talking about was a little
bit more of a concept that love is a
choice
and i made one and it was one of the
most life-changing choices of of my life
and i stand up for that more than i
would i would do the same thing all over
again this is a this is a time and
opportunity for me to be able to say
that i believe love is a choice and and
we all should support everyone's to have
their own private life and do what they
want to do if they're experiencing a
little bit of joy with another person